i christine Hamilton being the returning
officer at the election of a member of
parliament to the edmonton parliamentary
constituency held on Thursday the 18th
to 2017 do hereby give notice that the
number of votes recorded for each
candidate at the election is as follows
Donald Daniels the Conservative Party
candidate 10,000 106 Benjamin engine
James Kiehl Green Party 633 okay awesome
our labor and cooperative party 31,000
[Applause]
you
Thank You Omega okay
thirty 1221
Liberal Democrats 858 Nigel James Suzman
UK Independence Party 860 total number
ballot papers rejected was 113 the
turnout was 66 heightened City singers
percent I hereby declare that the said
hey autumn or
[Applause]
Parliament
thank you so much I would like to thank
the Electoral Officer my agent my
campaigns Inga Liza and myself and all
the Labour Party activists who are
overseeing the general election campaign
and also to the police the fire brigade
and the first-aid staff on duty today if
there is anyone out there who doubts
that Edmonton is a place where all
things are possible
just still wonders if the dream of hope
is alive in our time the school question
is the power of our democracy tonight is
your answer is the answer told by the
lines of people stretched around polling
stations schools and churches by young
people compute many for the first time
in their lives because they believed
that voting for labour this time must be
different that their voices could be the
difference whilst the national picture
is still slightly uncertain the
community of Edmonton have sent a strong
message it is a message of hope a voice
for the many not the few and a clear
opposition to hard
brexit knocking on doors and listening
to voters over the last several weeks it
is also clear that we as a community
have many challenges ahead as your MP I
will fight for proper funding of public
services and I will work with all
communities to tackle the growing
I would like to thank the hard-working
volunteers who contributed to this
campaign knocking on doors whether it
was raining or whether the Sun was
shining you made all the difference
and I'm really really grateful for all
your unwavering support I'm also proud
of the campaign we ran locally I'm proud
to of the campaign at the national level
labor ran a policy focused campaign
which offered a vision of hope and I
will continue to carry this hope forward
throughout the next parliament it has
been the greatest honor of my life to
represent you all in Parliament over the
last two years and I look forward to
continuing to serve as your MP thank you